salut clément ça va on se fait la bise
c'est une blague [ __ ] qc on peut
attraper des cars a pu sonder les
viateur et des magies carrefour masse ya
quoi là-bas il ya la mer je parle pas de
la dame parle de la merde à ce qu'elle
surmonte maman je pars de la mer
derrière la mer l'eau clé non [ __ ]
mais tu es qu il est débile
or la grosse ironie du sort c'est con à
la plage et cas que des pokémon
magnétique du coup va c'est tombé sur
lui vers tarbes et du magnétisme et on
va essayer de faire évoluer c'est notre
but aujourd'hui je met un petit temps
sans [ __ ] de merde
bon ça tu vois la bahia désherbe qui
bouge me demande pas pourquoi des herbes
qui bouge alors c'est du sable j'en sais
rien un kraby lors nérac en rien kramis
dans le sable ont ils fait dix fois
notre taille mais il ya un kraby hop là
est ce que ces deux captures parce que
les captures clément fils de [ __ ] plus
depuis quand même à les premières prises
un krabi 401 c'est pas des moindres à 1
volt org il est là il sur le rebord il
essaie d'impressionner en tournant sur
lui-même
je vais à planter jeu a planté sais ce
qu'ils te disent fait attention on
regarde autour de toi genre attention a
dit à tort qu'il va t'attaquer mais on a
tous envie qu'un radiateur nos
attaquants bref donc on a tous envie pas
faire attention autour de nous pour
tomber sur la ville attend tu comprends
la logique même bonjour il faudrait
qu'ils viendraient se remet bien sûr
c'est un minou tout par contre en
échange ale merci la tat bonne journée
tu vois tellement ça c'est quand les
gens te reconnaissent pour ce que tu
vaux mais pas pour ce que tu fais croire
que tu jamais été fort sur cette phrase
à le magnifier la attention je crois
qu'il est entre tes jambes bougent pas
ces fonds il est à côté de toi ils
volent ils level 34 médecins sketches
allez on continue que tu aimes bien ça
dans les chaussures avons ici de ça tu
vois c'est un mec du marché noir des
pokémon il ya un marché noir qui s'est
créé dans cette région ils vont tous les
magnetti et les vols trump qui trouve il
aimait dans des cartons il les ventes
sur la plage tu veux qu'on essaie d'en
vendre une qu'on estime manger pour te
montrer magnetti volts robe pas cher le
v70 sans plus manier tival trump tu vas
magnetti ou pas c'est quoi le toit que
ça restera voilà magnetti 20e
c'est ça c'est ça tu vas en volt web
assez le fit montre moi ce que tu vois
ça c'est fait magneti ventes rops et ça
c'est la technique
ameziane rivalité elle est terrible
cette rivalité je suis désolé ça lui il
essaie de mamadou et pour voler mais
pokemon faut pas qu'on sait se faire ré
ouais bon sens bon là bas
la légende dit qu'ils allaient bientôt
temps on va essayer de le paix chaud
c'est ce que c'est le problème sur cette
plage clément hormis lé sol qui me crame
les pieds c'est que les gens ont envie
de tendance à oublier qui est le
meilleur dresseur ne respecte pas on va
leur rappeler
je te présente pour le classe chailly
en dépit
mais
thomas
tu vois là le courant est pas bon il va
nous falloir un peu de ça il est levée
le 10 octobre retiens c'est tout autre
chose
tout alla et un taux qui a chopé lac
léman il ya un truc à chanter
[ __ ] bas
bon finalement voix oscille entre ses
mains donc là je t'explique tu te mets
là tu lances qui perd loin hyper loin
des lignes situées à lens pas loin tu
vas rien loupé mon gars tu auras même
pas un jeu d'enfant et là tu lances
étaient prêts ok donc là tu vois elle
est dans l'eau et à tout moment ça peut
mordre a donc on va attendre un peu et
puis je vais tenir au courant bon ça
devrait pas tarder à mornas ça fait
quand même une heure et demie tu fume
pas marie du cul je voyais les normes
c'est quoi ce bordel clement c'était
doré j'ai bu la tasse doré doré
non
tu vois que j'aime ça c'est des choses
qui arrivent toubon dresseur voulant
aller viator vit des choses comme ça
très décevante très des traumatismes
je suis traumatisé clairement c'est une
déception c'est un peu comme quand dans
un 9 5 km taratata quoi c'est clément
clément
c'est quoi ça
c'est un couple de dresseurs et vous les
choix que vous dire turin et bientôt
pourquoi les agréments proposer un
règlement vous offre votre d'acheteurs
bol
non bien des sciences mais ce à quoi bon
vieux style on arrive à l'un des
containers ils ont quand même
tahar attend les seins nus à la
dresseuse a les seins nus la dresseuse
quoi pas sauver son mec arrive à la
troisième place et tout va bien ça va
[ __ ] pas tout va bien ce matin tout va
bien placé plutôt calme tu me laisses
tes sont des atouts à sauver clémence
laventure à tes côtés était très
sympathique mais je pense que le destin
attend que moi et pas toi ça veut rien
dire mais tu vois ce que ça veut dire
seulement il faut que j'irai c'était un
plaisir j'espère que tu auras appris
plein de choses à mes côtés tu capture a
plein de pokémon rares moi j'ai eu ma
dose
il ya les victoires qui m'attend là bas
à bientôt clément je t'aime on se fait
la bise quand même pour la fin non c'est
une blague c'est une blague
inversement je te sois de voir capture
un jour je serai le maire pêcheur je
capturais plein de tweets